now this map shows where infection rates
have been concentrated in England since
the start of the epidemic but it only
gives a partial picture because it
doesn't include people tested in the
community now public health England is
watching the increase in infections in a
number of other places but it's worth
stressing they haven't recorded anywhere
near the same numbers as Leicester and
these certainly are not lists of areas
facing imminent lockdown and if you look
at the data for Leicester you see why
the seven-day infection rate unless
they're using both hospital and
community testing is a hundred and
thirty five cases per 100,000 people
which is three times higher than the
next highest city the Labour leader
kiaus Tama has accused the government of
failing the city by not providing
testing data more quickly they had data
for pillar 1 Kovach tests that's NHS
care workers and testing hospitals they
didn't have pillar 2 tests the wider
test in the community now that may sound
technical but what that meant what that
meant was that the local authority
thought that what 80 positive tests in
the last fortnight when the real figure
was 944 the local authority was only
given the real figure last Thursday so
there was a lost week so it all boils
down to which figures are looked at
Leicester was identified using local
data from what's called pillar 1 mainly
Hospital testing and pillar 2 testing
done in the community so once you factor
in the latest figures based on both
pillars 1 & 2 they show that Bradford
Barnsley and Rochdale came closest to
Leicester with 45 or more cases per
100,000 people but that's still quite a
long way behind left there so if we did
need to do a second plot down we could
we've also done it before but obviously
nobody wants that to happen we have
daily conversations with public health
England who are not have advising of a
second lockdown at the moment our cases
at least
going down day by day but they're still
higher than anybody would like and
therefore we need to redouble our
efforts and make sure they go down more
and to actually help people say safe now
at the moment public health England
doesn't publish daily figures from
community testing by local authority but
that's where three-quarters of
infections and now being identified
that's why this data will be critical to
spotting other hotspots and potential
local lockdowns